[Applause] gentlemen welcome to the new NHL
season it should be electric the start of a
new era in Chicago and perhaps in the National
Hockey League as well Bard Conor Bard Conor Bard
Bard Conor Bard Conor Bard Conor Bard here goes
bizard Bard Conor Bard Conor Bard Bard Bard Bard
Bard Bard Bard here's Bard would it be something
if Bard Bard Bard Bard Bard what' you think of
Conor Bard Conor Bard Conor Bard Conor bard Bard
again Bard Bard Bard again Conor Bard Bard Conor
Bard Bard Bard Bard Bard Bard got dumped Conor
Bard Conor Bard Conor Bard Conor Bard Conor Bard
Bard Conor Bard Conor Bard he was a factor all
night long a new look for a Tami paner show where
did that hair go he walked through the lobby today
and I thought we had a new player on the roster
if he waited long enough he wouldn't have to cut
it it would just gradually all go away he's got
the new look yeah playing the two on one poock
leaning in he's checked from behind they score
it looked like the Sharks had it sorted out but
they didn't David poock makes it three nothing
yeah it's another weird one Randy is the puck just
goes off of past's right skate and goes into the
net DUIs hustling pass derer he scores and that
one eludes Andre flurry somehow slipped between
his pads not 100% sure how that got through there
and the much all Canadian fans were hoping they
were going to get him he had the sweater done
a bit early he thought he'd have a good deal
on it see if he got it a hand price got it at
half price to prepare even though he had been
oh CET for heel he scores Philip heel gives the
Rangers a two nothing lead that's confirmed that
the player was offside no goal oh Steel by Z he
scored makers a b with a brilliant play after
video review is determined that the play was
offside therefore we have there's two wow it's
played out in front open man lightning and oh
it's kicked out no the referee s it cross the
line I thought it was kept down on the diving
effort by Jacob trouba oh here's a great look
and no you know I don't think it's in the video
review the puck did not completely cross what a
period this is there gos wiped off Joe I think
he went right-handed on that he did on the face
off he he's a left-handed shot but the face off
was on that side so he switched his hands around
and won the face off cleanly as a right-hander
you don't see that told you he was [Music] smart
it doesn't take long for someone
like William neander to figure out
a new position here's an example of
why his teammates are always willing
to go to bat for him helping wheel in the
equipment when the team got off the plane
earlier this morning looking for a new
deal he'll do anything to get that nail
down [Music] yeah um that's a pretty special
moment uh I was Dro it and he was uh born and
uh Jesus I'm old has Eric s duim scores
a short-handed goal for Brandon duim and
Minnesota's on the board first escapes duim
tried to go back to the line duim takes it
away here they go again duim with der this
time time duim fires from long range saved
by montmo and on the rebound they score derer
wins the fight one on three at the side of the
Montreal goal and flips it up over the shoulder
of montmo and Minnesota with two short-handed
goals on the same penalty kill will play by
Katon here's coni he's going in on goal the
short-headed man he scores backto back games
for the Flyers with a shorty he gets it back
walks to the slot the pass to connect the scores
Travis concy another shorty that's Walker out the
shot he scores it's Walker a second shortthe
headed goal on this power play a third short
headed goal in the game I can't ever remember
and I've watched a lot of hockey in my 46 years
where I've seen three short-handed goals in one
game Mark Stone the honor is yours [Applause]
Nashville at the Bridgestone Arena they
have decided oh my gosh I just I think I
just dropped my hot dog can you wipe
that down I just I just dropped oh
man I'm a loser cuz I'm definitely not a
wiener so there's cheese curds gravy and
fries well that's good I like it to be frank
with you I'll save you some if you want am I
truing it only fell on the floor it's no big
deal I know but there's a difference between
a normal floor and a hockey floor 5 second rule
trying to get that extra attack Ro as Monahan's
on the buck Monahan Jacky R her off the pipe
Harper Jacky nearly brought the insurance Harper
Jacky thinks it went in the net ooh the twine was
tickled that might have gone in the net that went
right through that's a goal that is a goal that
is you can see the black rubber Puck bur on the
mesh much ground then stepped up with the blue
line bouncing Puck yum knocked it down and they
score face off of s rice a high flip it a perfect
one with a little bit of spin on it and there it
is off the Stick of ma it never gets to kempe and
it's in the net behind gorv Joshua's gotten his
way to the Vancouver bench as the P out Escape
poly through on goal it might have been friendly
fire off of Vancouver skate but a pretty innocuous
looking Puck to the net that found its way past
arur shees coming around with he Stars his first
National Hockey League goal ah watch out D coming
for you buddy a press conference after you get
to the game hey where is my stick I know it's
here I got it I need it oh here it is the Red Wing
pitch Rond not out yet there's a thorn a bunch a
bunch of roses a white jersey and a sea of red
well said they enjoying that or what they like
Jordan Bennington to trim the Pediatrics there
was some frustration Jamie lurking around just
to see if it can get in his kitchen a little
bit does he go back to the crawl now I think
the answer is yes inching closer to the cape who's
Nets on to his forand he scores well that's over
20 stick handles I'll tell you that getting his
feet wet I'm not sure particularly oh how about
the Nifty work for Marino and he's stuck it
in off stoken very fortunate bounces ends up
going off es skate he probably shouldn't go down
there to his feet that's the only reason he goes
off thecate cter hu starting today Laura basas
the backup I'm not sure if that's your emergency
goal tender Kevin but uh he's ready to go with
the blocker got the trapper in five forino needs
help to get to the pitch it's like a five on three
yeah what you see the laugh but man what a tough
position he tried desperately to get a stick
on that one and almost did number 31 and time
for number [Music] [Applause] 49er fo fox fox
oh
go Octavio oh that was awesome I would do that
once and I'd lose my voice rest of the TR try
it by failing as he plays it in that pu took a
strange hop on cter her he's now caught in no
man's land in front it goes and pinno scores
their first shot in about a half a period of
hockey but it's in the net after the giveaway by
Carter the puck took a strange hop on him behind
the net and he never recovered 42 now hedo on
the right side tracked by pet up and over he
goes this building just came to life thanks to
Rasmus darene trying to turn on the Jets oh he
goes up an overall old school check we'll see
that for off Jared Davidson some Pace up the
left side Davidson centers right in front and
it squeaks through HCK actually takes out his
own goalie feed right here and that knocks
it across the goal line just by a [Music]
bit ganette dishes off soop shoots right
on rebound available is [__] down and
out really Greg can't believe he
didn't put this puck in the net
just a little tight oh ends up on his
back on the back back of his [Music]
leg their penalty kill second only to Boston
last year a turnover look out AO with speed
in decks scores short-handed goal fala tried to
make an extra stick handle and there is the he
just he over skates the puck saucers won it's
Cory Perry on wo he scores perries first as a
Blackhawk and he points to the crowd so the
hockey world is wondering so I have to ask
on your goal who are you pointing at well
it was funny uh the first first time out I
saw I saw Shane O'Brien and uh Scotty Upshaw
in the corner there and um and you I played
with both of them I know them really well and
uh you know when I scored I just g a little
point oh no
[Music] here's the re the CH begin with and
there's Crosby he's not let the boat going
0:10:59.040,1193:02:47.295
[Music]
to stay there a while look yeah he's smiling a
little bit that's brby leaving him in blistering
shot there hit the intended target Skinner for of
his neet to BL the B the G and it's in the oiler
net tie game shorthanded marker he comes out and
just tries to chip it over top of the Stick of
aalo he's got his blade down the ice he just wants
to kind of shovel this one through aalo it doesn't
go he stays with it KY docks got it slowski in
front scores and Alex new hook has his first
first goal as a Montreal Canadian here's what you
want to see a youngster with a smile on his face
can't believe exactly what happened his crossy
speed not played cleanly by kachuck Lowry lost
the stick but he'll boot it ahead he gets a stick
in full flight Lowry for appeton is it in it's SC
appeton puts it in are you ready for this Lowry
no stick is moris he going to get a second assist
for this one as he dishes off The Twig Lowry
makes the pass to the middle of the ice what
a beautiful sequence of heads up play from Josh
Morrison and a thank you to morrisy from Lowry
lead off man for the Canadians is their Captain
Suzuki will swing wide and fumbled up and neither
team able to score on their opening tries Carlson
behind the net sweep one out the front good job by
T who puts it in his own neck Tana tried to carry
it behind the cage play it towards the net and it
carams in two nothing Vegas it may have gone off
the Stick of marsh so it looks like he'll get the
goal now the crowd is giving it to the leaps a
bit yelling you got Florida if you recall last
year there were some Le fans saying we want
Florida they got him coyotes get a clear Dy
pressured buat now bumped on the play by Dodie we
got Dodie and dowy out there thanks very much Todd
cutting to the Nets far post is that puck across
the line can't see from here Thompson trying to
bury it into the flex up and out of play and say
goodbye to that stick I'm going to yeah it was
toast there the first time Peach second time he
made sure yeah look at him he's frustrated with
[Applause]
himself